after many years of trying to recapture
the success she found on True Detective
in the film world didario found herself
joining another Anthology series on HBO
in 2021 with the White Lotus in the
season one Ensemble didario plays Rachel
a newly wed on her honeymoon who starts
to second guess whether marrying Jake
Lacy's character an unfathomable jerk
was a good idea the first season
premiered to critical Acclaim and
garnered a whole bunch of Emmy
nominations with the Dario netting one
for outstanding supporting actress in a
limited series or Anthology which she
lost to co-star Jennifer kulich as a
whole fans responded positively to
Dario's performance as Rachel who we can
safely say is more nuanced and relatable
than her character and True Detective as
Dario told The Hollywood Reporter the
role came at a point in her career where
she felt like she was lacking Direction
and Drew upon that in her performance
saying like my character there have
definitely been times I felt
misunderstood or not breaking through
and I feel like I took it all somewhat
in stride with critical approval and Nei
nomination behind her D's future was
entirely up to her now